we have the absolute value of 2 R minus
3 and 1/4 is less than 2 and 1/2 and we
want to solve for R so right from the
get-go we have to deal with this
absolute value and just as a bit of a
review if I were to say that the
absolute value of x is less than well
let's just say less than 2 and 1/2 that
means that the distance from X to 0 is
less than 2 and 1/2 that means that X
would have to be X would have to be less
than 2 and 1/2 and X would have to be
greater than negative 2 and 1/2 and just
think about it for a second if I were to
draw it on a number line right here if I
were to draw it on a number line that is
0 that is 2 and 1/2 and that is negative
2 and 1/2 these two numbers are exactly
2 and a half away from 0 because both of
their absolute values is 2 and a half
now if we want all of the numbers whose
absolute value is less than 2 and 1/2 or
that are less than 2 and 1/2 away from 0
it would be all of the numbers in
between it would be all the numbers in
between and that's exactly what these
two statements are saying X has to be
less than 2 and 1/2 and it has to be
greater than negative 2 and 1/2
if this absolute value were the other
way the absolute value of x has to be
greater than 2 and 1/2 that would be the
numbers outside of this and it would be
an or but we're dealing with a less than
situation right there so let's just do
what we were able to figure out when it
was just an X the distance from this
thing the distance from this thing to 0
has to be less than 2 and 1/2 so we can
write we can write that 2r minus 3 and
1/4 can either well it has to be less
than 2 and 1/2 and and 2r minus 3 and
1/4 has to be greater than negative 2
and 1/2 same exact reasoning here let me
draw a line so we don't get confused
same exact reasoning here this quantity
right here has to be between negative 2
and 1/2 it has to be greater than
negative 2 and 1/2 right there greater
than negative 2 and 1/2 and it has
be less than two and a half so that's
all I wrote there so let's solve each of
these independently well this first one
over here you've learned before that I
don't like well I don't like improper
fractions and I don't like fractions in
general so let's make all of these
fractions or sorry I don't like mixed
numbers I want them to be improper
fraction so let's turn all of these into
improper fractions so if I were to
rewrite it we get 2 R minus 3 and 1/4 is
the same thing as 3 times 4 is 12 plus 1
is 13 - R - thirteen - thirteen fourths
is less than two times two is four plus
one is five is less than five halves so
that's the first equation and then the
second equation and do the same thing
here we have 2 R minus 13 over four has
to be greater than negative five-halves
all right now let's solve each of these
independently to get rid of the
fractions the easiest thing to do is to
multiply both sides of this equation by
4 that'll eliminate all of the fractions
so let's do that let's multiply let me
scroll to the left a little bit let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
4 and what do we get 4 times 2 R is 8r 4
times negative 13 over 4 is negative 13
is less than and I multiplied by a
positive number so I didn't have to
worry about swapping the inequality is
less than 5 halves times 4 is 10 right
it becomes you get a 2 and a 1 it's 10
so you get 8 R minus 13 is less than 10
now we can add 13 to both sides of this
equation so that we get rid of it on the
left hand side a dirty non both sides
and we get 8r these guys cancel out is
less than is less than 23 and then we
divide both sides by 8 divide both sides
by 8 and once again we didn't have to
worry about the inequality because we're
dividing by a positive number and we get
R is less than 23 23 over 8 or if you
want to write that as a mixed number R
is less than was that two and seven two
and seven eighths
so that's one condition but we still
have to worry about this other condition
there was an and right here let's worry
about it so our other condition tells us
to our minus 13 over 4 has to be greater
than negative five-halves let's multiply
both side of this equation by 4 so 4
times 2r is 8r 4 times negative 13 over
4 is negative 13 is greater than
negative five-halves times 4 is negative
10 now we add 13 to both sides of this
equation
add 13 to both sides of this equation
the left-hand side these guys cancel out
you're just left with 8 R is greater
than negative 10 plus 13 is 3 or divide
both sides of this by 8 and you're left
with R has to be greater than 3/8 so our
two conditions all has to be less than 2
and 7/8 and greater than 3/8 or we could
just write it like this R is greater
than 3/8 so it's greater than or maybe I
should say 3/8 is less than R which is
less than 2 and 7/8 2 and 7/8 so if we
were to plot the solution on the number
line so I'm about to do so that's my
number line this is zero right here
maybe this is 1 2 & 3 we have 2 and 7/8
so we have to be less than 2 and 7/8
let's say that this is 2 and 7/8 right
there and we have to be greater than 3/8
say that is 3/8 so 3/8 will be someplace
right around there and everything in
between is a valid solution everything
in between is a valid solution and we
could try it out let's try out something
that based on what I just drew should be
a valid solution 1 should be a valid
solution let's try it out here 2 times 1
let's do it 2 times 1 minus 3 and 1/4
what is that that's 2 minus 3 and 1/4
and so what is that 2 minus 3 and 1/4 is
well 3 and 1/4 minus 2 is 1 and 1/4 so
this will be negative 1 and 1/4
negative 1 and 1/4 we're taking the
absolute value of it so we take the
absolute value of it which is equal to 1
and 1/4 which is indeed less than 2 and
1/2 now let's try another number let's
try 0 based on this zero should not work
so what happens if we put 0 here you get
2 times 0 which is 0 minus 3 and 1/4 you
take the absolute value of minus of
negative 3 and 1/4 look at positive 3
and 1/4 which won't work 3 and 1/4 is
greater than 2 and 1/2 so that work
that's true that works out and the same
thing for 3 2 times 3 is 6 minus 3 and
1/4 is 2 and 3/4 take the absolute value
it's 2 and 3/4 it's still bigger than 2
and 1/2 so it won't work
so at least the points that we try it
out seem to validate this solution that
we got